I remember prepping him for interviews
at the end of the administration saying
they're gonna ask you your legacy is
gonna be and said look I read three
books about George Washington last year
and if historians are still analyzing
the first president then the forty-third
doesn't have a lot to worry about
because he'll never know
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special and I'm
really excited to be joined today by
Dana Perino she's hosted the daily
briefing and co-host of the five Dana
great to see you
it's amazing to finally get to do the
sunday show I know the best Sunday show
oh thanks Chris Wallace well for people
who don't know your background and have
only seen you on Fox News you first rose
to prominence as President Bush's press
secretary but what was yeah how did you
get into politics before that it's funny
I um I worked a Karl Rove's book and a
couple of others and I remember he Carl
wanted to write just from when he was
the president's campaign manager in 1998
and I remember the editor saying you
can't just show up as that the
president's campaign manager you have to
understand how and those were always
that kind of the hardest first chapters
for people to write Charles Krauthammer
was the same when I worked with him
peggy noonan didn't even want to do it
but i do think it's really important and
it's one of things I love about your
show is to dig a little deeper like how
did you get to be this person and well
my family's from Wyoming both of my
great grandparents on my maternal and my
paternal side homesteaded in Wyoming one
became more of a entrepreneur like with
a motel that there's iat goes right
through Wyoming big trucking route and
so they had a motel there and a couple
of other things but I feel like maybe
where I identify the most is with my
great grandparents ranch in Wyoming
so it was the late 1800s they came from
Italy my great-grandfather was a coal
miner he did that all the way up to the
60s he did die of black lung
he and my great-grandmother had eight
children seven survived one of them was
what was my grandfather and it's in the
Black Hills of Wyoming a lot of people
think because I worked for the president
I'm either from Texas and I knew the
bushes or that when I say I'm from
Wyoming there's sort of this oh then you
must know the chaining is like I didn't
know the Cheney's either the Cheney's
were from the other side of the state
the Black Hills is about 80 miles west
of Mount Rushmore both the ranches right
by the Devils Tower so it's a pretty
rugged country good cattle country and
my grandfather thought that he wanted to
be a doctor
and so he was on that path however World
War two happened and he then went and
fought in the Pacific and the Marines
had him trained as a medic but like with
many of those veterans they felt like
they had seen the world at that point
and they were done with it and he was
needed back on the ranch he goes home
but before he went home he comes down
through the Panama Canal up in the dock
in Philly that's when he's gonna
decommission war was over and a friend
of his said we want to set you up on a
blind date tonight and my grandmother's
friend said we want to set you on a
blind date tonight both of them refused
to go until the last minute and it was
love at first sight and they got married
and had three children so my dad was the
oldest of three yeah I think he knew
early on that he didn't want to be a
long time lifelong rancher the first one
to go to college at University of
Wyoming one of the things about my dad
that maybe helps explain me later
is he loved news and he loved debate and
so he used to said this before like
speech teams existed he at the
University of Wyoming at least he and
his roommates would take a topic and
they would debate it take one side take
a break
and then have to argue the other side so
he and my mom met at Casper College and
I was the oldest of two when I was two
and a half my dad got a job with Western
Farm Bureau life insurance company we
moved to Denver and my dad's when the
third grade started this tradition where
I had to read the Rocky Mountain News in
the Denver Post before he got home from
work and I had to choose two articles to
discuss before dinner and I flashed
forward a little bit for you any you
have a daughter for anyone that has a
daughter and there may be concerned like
how do you raise a confident young
person and I'm not excluding boys I just
know my own experience my this is the
early days of feminist marketing there
was this yellow t-shirt my dad bought me
and in all-black capital letters it said
anything boys can do girls can do better
which of course is not true but it's one
of those things where my dad was always
like you can do whatever you want you
know but having
that opportunity to express myself and
defend my positions about why I chose
this article why do I think it's
important
gave me I think the confidence later on
to do that with the President of the
United States and I really encourage
that kind of interaction with young
women at their at their earliest ages if
anybody that's watching if they can can
do that one thing that people don't
realize I don't think until the Camilla
Harris Biden dust-up at that first
debate this year is that Denver was the
city that was the subject of the busing
desegregation a bit lost in the Supreme
Court Denver then was the first to try
to integrate schools using busing and so
when I was in the fourth grade instead
of going to the school that was three
blocks away around my home
I got bus 20 miles in the city I was one
of only four white kids in the whole
school I was talking to my mom about it
and she said it's not that you didn't
make friends though I remember it kind
of differently she said that on the
weekends or after school there was no
one to play with she didn't know anybody
and then because I got bullied and all
the rest I would have this anxiety about
what if they get mad at me like what if
they don't like me tomorrow and I would
pray over and over again in this rote
fashion like I hope they're not mad at
me tomorrow if they're not mad at me
tomorrow but so my parents end up after
two years of that moving to a rural part
of Colorado and that's where we grew up
went to University of Southern Colorado
on a speech team scholarship went to
graduate school University of Illinois
Springfield as getting a degree is going
to be a reporter and I like covering
politics that was what I really wanted
to do but you can't always cover
politics the state legislature is not in
session you got to do other things and
one day the station I worked for a CBS
affiliate said they wanted me to go
cover this murder trial this young boy
two years old had been murdered by this
woman's best friend who she'd been
living with and the trial was starting
and they said go and get a interview
with this woman and I went to the
courthouse and I circled her three times
and I said oh I can't do this and I went
home and I told my dad I said I think I
just
got a graduate degree in something I
don't want to do and he was great he
said um as soon as did you graduate then
we'll just you come home and I'll figure
it out
ended up going to Washington worked as a
house press secretary for a congressman
from Colorado who's chairman of the
energy and Power subcommittee which is
how I kind of a nerd on climate change
issues environmental issues and know
them very well that's actually how I get
back to the White House after 9/11 my
girlfriend called and said could you
come join us at the Justice Department
and then from there I became press
secretary so in a second I want to ask
you about working in the Bush
administration what that was like and
I'm asking that President Bush and being
press secretary but first let's talk
about life insurance now there are a lot
of folks who think about getting life
insurance like why bother you know is
that really such a big deal the answer
is yes it's a giant deal you should have
life insurance if you're an adult you
got to make sure that your family is
taken care of so don't be chicken about
going to get life insurance especially
when it's easy if you got a family you
might be dealing with something a little
scarier right now than searching for
life insurance not having life insurance
so go shop for life insurance if the
idea of looking for life insurance
though doesn't imitate you there's an
easy solution policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in just
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home insurance and auto
insurance and disability insurance
policy genius will give you the peace of
mind that you require when you go out
into the world because you know God
forbid get hit by a bus at least your
family's taken care of this October take
the scariness out of buying life
insurance with policy genius go to
policy genius.com get quotes apply in
magic into the whole thing on your phone
right now
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance okay so let's
talk about your time in the Bush
administration so when did you actually
first get to know President Bush so you
joined the administration is in the DOJ
but that doesn't necessarily mean you
know the president so how did you
actually get to know the president well
I started trying to think of when I
first he might have known about me I had
worked with Ari Fleischer on Capitol
Hill Josh Bolten
was a big fan of mine so was ante card
because I had been doing the White House
Council on Environmental Quality press
for the White House for a long time now
media bias is not new okay and being
hard on Republicans on environmental and
conservation issues is not new we were
on the front page every single day in
fact I'll tell you something that a lot
of people don't know on September 10th
2001 what was the White House
communications office working on stayed
till 10 p.m. at the White House big
issue front page New York Times story
come in the next day they got a problem
on their hands
it was the Cheney energy task force
right the next morning the world changes
forever and you look back on that now
and like oh my gosh we should have just
said yeah of course Cheney is chairing
the energy task force you idiots of
course yeah but it's just a different
time but I did all the stuff on Bureau
of Land Management all the climate
change issues there was a issue about
coal-fired power plants called new
source review that the Clinton
administration had been very clever in
filing these little lawsuits little time
bombs that would pop up and then the
administration and the next
administration would have to decide are
you going to pursue this ridiculous
lawsuit against these coal-fired power
plants and if you're not does that mean
you're a dirty polluter so we dealt with
a lot of that but I started in the White
House press office as the deputy on the
first day of the second term and got to
know me then so that's the kind of funny
story I feel like the first time he ever
really knew who I was I got kicked out
of the Oval Office this is one of my
most embarrassing moments but Dan
Bartlett communications director he said
Dana would you mind sitting in with the
president as he does his interview with
David Ignatius David Ignatius has just
returned from Iran president's great to
sit down with him and they're gonna this
conversation and I'll come for the
pre-brief for the president but I have
to go this other meeting can you just
sit yeah I know how to do that most
pretty nervous my first time sitting
with the president Oval Office
syndicated columnist so we get to the
Oval Office
Dan's starting to explain this what's
happening he said mr. president David
Ignatius is here is gonna and the
president says oh I'm not doing an
interview with Ignatius and Dan said no
you are remember we talking he said no I
said I would talk to David Ignatius
about his trip but I'm not going to do
an interview with David Ignatius because
then he'll write about it and then it
will look like I'm negotiating with the
radians through david ignatius and i'm
not doing it and therefore she doesn't
need to be here and he looked at me i
don't think he knew my name and he gave
me one of these head nods to basically
like get out of the oval office so i
leave by the grandfather clock and i i
think my office was like thirty steps
away go down to lower press office i'd a
pocket door i closed it and i called
peter my husband and said I was tearful
I wasn't crying but I was cheerful and
so what happened tell us and he said
well just think for the rest of your
life you can say I've been kicked out of
better places than this but then over
time the president got to know me one of
the things I think is a one of my my
highest compliments I got from him is
that he was never surprised by a
question from the press when i briefed
him that was like super cover i have all
the bases covered
Loes his relationship with the press
like because obviously you know now we
have short memories and everybody
pretends that as you say the fake news
began with President Trump and that no
president has ever been hit by the press
like like President Trump some of us are
old enough to remember when george w
bush was president they were calling him
but hitler and suggesting that he was a
war criminal so what how did you handle
press relations
well yeah you kind of do have to go back
in time a little bit remember he had
watched his father go through media bias
remember the WIMP the wind factor that
was in the cup run covered newsweek I
believe President Bush kind of never got
over that for his on his dad's behalf
like if you insulted 41 in 43 as well
call them both said it was harder to be
the father of a president and the son of
a president than it was to be the
president because of the criticism when
it's when the criticism is aimed at you
you can kind of handle it but if it's
about your loved one it's different by
the time I come on the scene he's seen
his dad go through it he's been elected
governor of Texas twice he's gone
through the recount he's in war and he's
been reelected and he had a respect for
the First Amendment and he also was his
father's son and so there was respect
was to be given to the press and also
the president gave me a real
a leg up he told everybody in the
administration if you are at a meeting
and you go back to your desk and you
have message that Dana Perino called
she's a first person you call back
because I would say unlike today it's
just a different now but I would spend
85% of my day preparing for the press
briefing and part of that was being in
meetings listening helping shape the
message and all of those things but it
was really press relations
I do remember ed gillespie however the
communications director at the time
strategic advisor for the president
started a thing called setting the
record straight and it was a document
that we used to put out we would take an
article and now it's this is a common
this happens on Twitter all the time or
it happened to the well you think at the
but with the New York Times and
Cavanaugh that happened immediately we
would try to do that from the White
House or from the RNC they would they
would give that a shot I have this one
young man Carlton Carroll I remember we
used to announce over the intercom that
we had put a press release in the bins
of people at the White House and Carlton
Carroll over the intercom said there's a
studying the record straight in the bins
and I suggest you read it that was kind
of our push back um
Bill O'Reilly used to give me a little
bit of a hard time and commercial breaks
saying that I was too easy on the press
and looking back I think maybe that's
true maybe that's true but I also had
good relations where especially with the
White House press corps I don't think I
would change how I handled it because I
used to think if I'm speaking in front
of them at the podium if the press if
the president were watching me I would
think if would he be proud of what I was
saying and if the answer was no I didn't
say so how has the job of press
secretary change because now we've seen
obviously that that position elevated is
such an important point in American life
that people aren't allowed to appear on
Dancing with the Stars if they if they
apparently dissembled from the honestly
roasting you the contrary magazine on
the same night that Sean Spicer did
Dancing with the Stars
I think I was probably even more nervous
than Sean Spicer was because he has a
life and he I mean you weren't wearing
like a green no I knew that I was the
only female roaster so I was like I'm
wearing the white dress be a little
different I think technology has changed
a lot of things Marlin fit
water is one of my favorite people he
was press secretary to Reagan and Bush
imagine being press secretary for eight
years his book called the briefing is
probably one of the best ever written
about Washington experiences and I
recommend it highly to anybody who's
thinking about going to Washington well
fast forward from Marlin Fitzwater to
Mike McCurry now he's President
Clinton's press secretary he's the first
to allow cameras into the briefing room
that changes the dynamic a lot he says
he regrets it I think was kind of
inevitable maybe people want the video
in January of 2009 on the day that I
leave the White House I didn't even have
a Twitter account and the Obama team
really takes social media to the next
level to win the election they use it a
little bit differently but I do think
that sort this my own perspective I've
done no research on this but it's my gut
that just as radio change things for FDR
and and forever and at the time people
like what is he doing this is so
inappropriate he's on the radio that's
and then you get to Kennedy all the way
through Reagan and the use of television
and that changes everything and I do
think that whether you like the tweets
or you don't like the tweets the fact
that the President of the United States
communicates directly not through the
media that has changed things I don't
think it's for the better or the worse I
think it's fascinating and I still think
there is a role for the Pres it's
interesting
conservatives tend to hate the press
until the press writes a good article
then it's like well look what the New
York Times even the New York Times wrote
that I had a rule in my office always
read the article twice before you
complain about it and that helps soften
things so your relationship with
President Bush was obviously very close
amendment that when you were press
secretary your message was much more on
message with with President Bush's how
would you answer questions where you
didn't quite know what the president
thought because that that obviously the
gap between the president in the press
secretary has been very obvious in this
administration where the press secretary
will go out there at least early on say
something the president will then
undercut that or the press secretary in
fear that they might cross the president
will give some bizarre answer on
something that might normally seem sort
of obvious to to everybody this is a
great question I have a great story
about our
action one of the things as DD Myers was
given bad information actually given bad
information from the National Security
Council about a strike was I can think
it was in Afghanistan actually and she
had been at the White House on a
Saturday reporters asked her like hey
we're hearing about activity she goes
and she has the National Security
Council they say no it's not happening
she tells that to the press because they
were afraid they didn't want to upset
the operation but that hurt her
incredibly fast forward never Scott
McClellan gets into this thing is like
well I whatever he said he heard that
was so I'm I was hyper aware one I never
ever ever want to get in trouble for
anything I like the gold star on the
chart at the end of the day so I would
be super cautious about things like that
the other thing is and I think Obama and
M Trump are like this as well President
Bush let me be with him anytime I wanted
so I would listen to all of the things
that he would say I didn't always raise
my hand I could raise my hand if I
wanted to but I could observe everything
so the story I was gonna say about this
is the only time I didn't double-check
to make sure was really high stakes I
woke up one morning four o'clock was
born I used to get four twelve he would
wake up my alarm was at four twenty but
I woke up before twelve and there's all
these emails that say from reporters
they want to know what the president
thinks about prime minister maliki of
Iraq sending troops into Basra and I'm
like let me know I'm just still drying
my hair guys I'll get back to you as
soon as I can then they're all even and
I don't know what came over me
except for that I had been with the
president so much I'd been in all the
secure video teleconferences with Maliki
and Karzai and finally I say about 5:45
in the morning I think I gave it to
Reuters I said the President of the
United States supports Prime Minister
Maliki and reminds everyone that this is
exactly what the world was thinking
Malik you wouldn't do but he did it to
help protect the minority there in Iraq
in Basra because Basra was a mess about
five minutes later all these articles
start coming in from the wire services
Petraeus is furious with Maliki Gates is
furious
rice is furious nobody knew that this
was happening they're so mad at Maliki
and I thought oh my gosh I could get
fired today I really did think that my
stomach sank I was so nervous get to the
White House senior staff meetings late
Bush White House was never late Josh
Bolten comes into the Roosevelt Room
from The Oval Office side not his office
and he's standing there instead of
sitting down he said I haven't met I
just came from the Oval Office
I'm until everybody in this room that if
anyone here says that the president
doesn't support Prime Minister Maliki
they are wrong and I had to fill piece
of paper I was like I said it I said
he's on record I have it like it's like
it's there in 2009 2008 2008 2009 we did
interviews with Charles Krauthammer four
of them that Charles decided never to
publish that was it was up to him and
Charles says to the president when did
you know that the surge was going to be
a success president says well Basra and
when Maliki sent the troops in and
nobody thought he would do it and he
says you know Charles nobody in my
administration was with me except for
Dana and that he remembered meant a lot
to me so we were I just I tell that
story to say look we were super close I
understood him he understood me and we
have you know in a lot of ways he was
like a second father to me but you know
if the if he has commander-in-chief had
asked me to mop the floors for eight
years I would have done it so in a
second I want to ask you about what the
press always gets wrong about george w
bush well guess that in one second first
who really wants to go to the post
office I mean the post office is great I
mean they provide great services but do
you really want to slip all your stuff
to the post office in the back of your
car and unload it all and you have to
wait in line here's what you need a way
to get all the services of the post
office without actually going to the
post office you need stamps calm it's
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps calm
will eliminate trips to the post office
and save you time and money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office
stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease simply use your
two prints official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it off in a mail box it
is indeed that simple with stamps calm
you get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
stamps calm it's a no-brainer they'll
save you time it will save you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale with no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on that microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro okay so let's talk
about what the press gets wrong about
George W Bush so I mean I was you know
covering from afar what was happening
with the Bush administration and the and
the typical press sort of account of
President Bush is that he was a bumbler
and that he was a clod and that he and
that he was indecisive and that still
kind of maintains to a certain extent in
the press to be the narrative although
now they're redrawing it because they
hate Trump so much that any Republican
who came before is is by proxy normal
and good but what was that like I mean
you knew him personally obvious it
wasn't personal it was frustrated I
don't know if you've ever worked with
somebody that that you know to have so
much you have so much respect for them
and you see them behind closed doors and
then in front of the camera it just
doesn't translate sometimes and I think
he tried really hard to connect with
common man like if we went and did an
interview he loved the crew didn't care
about the talent he loved the crew right
so like behind the scenes people knew so
we started doing these things these
off-the-record meetings on foreign
policy we would invite reporters in the
New York Times I think refused to come
because it was off the record but
everybody else came is like fine well if
you don't want to get the president's
thinking whatever fine we don't don't
come and to a person they would leave
and say wow why isn't that the person
that you see on TV and I think you know
a president has multiple audiences that
they're talking to all at the same time
the American people our troops our
allies and our enemies
and you have to keep all of those things
in mind and I think I don't know if they
realize how funny he was and what also
here's another thing that really bothers
me this is how I had a reporter who
wrote a book about working in Washington
for women and working in Washington and
she called me and she says so how hard
was it to be in the bush bro White House
what are you talking about I was the
press secretary if I needed something on
foreign policy
I called condi rice it was homeland
security I called Fran Townsend got an
education question I'm gonna call marker
Spelling's you know counsel's office
Harriet Miers ledge affairs that was
candy wolf I could go on but I think
I've made my point here too and it's
very frustrating that he was he was a
promoter of women but we didn't promote
it in turn that we didn't put out a
press release every time a woman
achieved a new position just because it
was on the merits that's how it was just
a meritorious situation there were gay
people that worked in the Bush
administration now a lot of people did
come out after the administration but I
also think you know when when gay
marriage became accepted and the Supreme
Court ruled that changed so fast with
society I feel like people think he was
quite an intolerant person and he was
not how did you handle leaks in the
White House so that's obviously been a
huge issue with this with this
administration and there were some
problems with leaks in the early Bush
administration by the second term it
seemed like that had been locked down
pretty well like I can't even remember a
leak that we had to deal with actually
one time I did think there was a leak
and then the president said no that was
Hadley because Steve Hadley had given
some information about it anyway I know
we didn't really have leaks though if
there ever was a leak I think it's so
interesting you can take it to the bank
the press office never leaks because
they have to clean up the leaks but
they're always suspected of the leak but
I tell you it's almost a hundred percent
foolproof that the first person to
complain about a leak is the leaker
well the He Who smelt it dealt at the
area I remember it from the John Roberts
nomination there
was somebody in the counsel's office and
something came it was in the paper like
halfway that's not accurate that's not
true
get this call at 6:40 in the morning
from a guy never even really talked to
and I realized like oh he's the leaker
so let's fast forward from the Bush
administration to now you're on Fox News
so what was that transition back into TV
and news like for you because you
started off there and you yeah although
what I was doing when I couldn't get the
land the interview at the courthouse was
very different from what I do now I knew
when I left the Bush administration that
I wanted to stay in the conversation I
also wanted to be somebody that could
continue to defend and promote the
legacy of George W Bush and I enjoyed
explaining things to people
I enjoyed that one of the things I made
the mistake of doing and a lot of people
do this when they leave public service
is you say yes to everything I was
burning the candle at both ends
I was working later hours than I had
when I had been at the White House so
eventually after just being a
contributor for a while being the guest
I I almost always for those first two
years was defending the Bush
administration because you remember
President Obama remember get him up he
would say it over and over again it was
a constant a gentle respectful way of
pushing back and setting the record
straight so I did that and then I got
nominated by McConnell and then
President Obama agreed and I got Senate
confirmed to the broadcasting Board of
Governors which oversees Voice of
America like I do a lot of work and care
a lot about Africa was kind of born and
put into me by the bushes and I was
coming back from Nigeria I was at Dulles
Airport and I got a call asking me if I
could come up to New York for five weeks
to do this temporary program with five
people at a table and that was eight
years ago so we moved up here and did
that I think the hardest thing was as
press secretary I was very used to
explaining somebody else's decisions
explaining their decision making I could
tell you exactly why he did it what what
his opinion was I knew all of that it
wasn't until I came on the five that
I was challenged to say well what do you
think and I realized that there's a big
buffer in that because if I'm fine your
spokesperson it's not me that they're
criticizing right so that was new for me
I remember Greg Gutfeld at one point
turned to me he said no what do you
think not what the administration
thought like what do you think about I
think it was the legalization of
marijuana and I really had to spend some
time thinking about it and think about
how I would articulate I think that was
the hardest part and then also for a
while maybe this is just true of every
it might not be true of every network
but it for a while because the show was
called temporary and everything is
temporary right you could be fired at
any time that could happen I I wasn't
sure am I going to have to leave doing
this commentary work and go back and
being a spokesperson for somebody or
doing PR work etc and when I finally
realize oh I can let go I've been sort
of having more fun so I want to go back
for a second you mentioned the legacy of
George W Bush and President Bush's
famously said that you know he only
thinks that his legacy is getting Burton
a hundred years after his presidency and
then we'll really sort of know well
we're not a hundred years out but we are
eleven years out from his presidency or
ten years out from his presidency what
do you think that that the Bush
administration's legacy is in President
Bush's legacy will be
I really have to hand it to him for
having this viewpoint
I remember prepping him for interviews
at the end of the administration saying
they're gonna ask you your legacy is
gonna be and he said look I read three
books about George Washington last year
and if historians are so analyzing the
first president then the forty-third
doesn't have a lot to worry about
because he'll never know Abraham Lincoln
went you know unfortunately murdered
dies thinking is unpopular right and and
so no I don't think that they'll ever
really know I I think that looking
through the prism of today you know I'll
even have people say to me oh you know I
really miss real Republicans and I
understand what they mean in terms of
civility like if that's if they're
looking for civility but I also believe
and I learned this from President Bush
democracy is self-healing and we have
the greatest country's been through so
much we've been through a lot worse 43
used to talk to me about when he
graduated from college how terrible the
actually fighting each other in the
streets in the late 60s and we're a long
way from that I think that his work with
veterans will continue obviously 9/11 is
the turning point for so many things and
for a presidency that was supposed to be
about returning to domestic policy the
tax cuts early on might improve
education less government no foreign
nation building oh that all changes in a
moment out of necessity and I think that
is something I think will people will
look back and say he was able to focus
the mind and through his strategy was to
help other presidents for the future
have tools in place to help protect the
country from it ever happening again I
think that that will be the most
important part of the legacy
I'd be remiss if I didn't talk a little
bit about the war rocks you mentioned a
little bit earlier and it is fascinating
to see how so many people on the right
have now run headlong from from the war
in Iraq suggesting that not only was it
was it based on bad information which is
you know fairly fairly true at least
with regard to the weapons of mass
destruction but that it was immoral or
that or that it was fought for for
nefarious reasons or oil for oil and and
and I'm talking about leaders in the
Republican Party suggesting this that
the Bush era foreign policy was truly a
liberal foreign policy I've heard folks
on various networks suggest and what do
you make of that sort of recasting of
the Iraq war as something that I mean
I'm old enough to remember when
Republicans spent eight years defending
it so what do you make of that so I
really like decision points President
Bush's autobiography he takes 14
decisions of his presidency and explains
them and what I also like about it is he
said I'm done debating it right so I'm
gonna tell you what I knew at the time
you can't you can't force people to have
a legacy based on information they
didn't have at the time and I still
maintain that the world is better off
without Saddam Hussein and I hurt for
our veterans that have come back and
have injury and for the ones who didn't
come back for the gold star families
I do think that defending what they did
why they went how many how many young
people volunteered it's it's an
incredible number because they believed
in freedom that was the other thing is
that this innate belief in freedom that
was a rallying cry and now it seems
quaint and to me I I look at all around
the world like solving problems at their
source will help a lot of things would
help a lot of things our immigration
problem at the border for example law
and order things like that I also feel
like the national security reasons for
why you go to war was there a threat was
there a credible threat one thing I
admire about President Bush as well is
that he never blamed the Intelligence
Agency
he never did that because he knew as
president he needed them right and that
they had it wrong things can go wrong
and I think that he as he writes in his
book if he had other information at the
time would he have gone to war no that's
not the information that he had so let's
fast forward to today's politics and
talk about what's going on now so
obviously things are incredibly
different than they were in 2008 even in
2004 and we are living in this bizarro
world in which in which President Trump
is the president and that is a shocking
development for people who are
traditional followers of politics
because obviously came from literally
nowhere in the political landscape like
and just steamrolled over all the other
primaries everybody's okay
so first I want to get your sort of
analysis of what the hell happened in
2016 because we have a bunch of
competing sort of narratives about what
happened in 2016 on the right you have
this narrative the president Trump put
together this brand new coalition that
never been done before driving people
out to vote like no one in history and
on the left you have this idea that
President Trump stole the election and
that truly Hillary Clinton was just sort
of a failure recreating the coalition of
Barack Obama but that the new normal is
Obama's coalition and Trump is an
outlier how do you analyze well I'm
definitely with the former I think the
latter is really dangerous for dem if
Democrats think that they're going to
lose again I'm also
troubled by this notion do you have
actual Democrats and many women
Democrats saying a woman can't can't put
a woman up in 2020 because a woman just
can't be President Trump because America
is not ready to vote for a woman I think
wait Hillary actually won the popular
vote mate she screwed up her strategy in
three states and so I feel like all this
women's empowerment nonsense that you
hear from Democrats basically saying oh
we actually we can't beat him okay
I actually think that the popular vote
might not be achievable for for
President Trump though he's given it a
shot going to New Mexico going to
California if you can increase those
vote totals there even if he doesn't win
those stays New Mexico might be in the
cards California obviously is not but if
you can increase the number of people
that vote for you then improve on the
popular vote that would be that would be
something I also think that Americans
were much more ready for change than
traditional politicians or political
observers thought they were much more
comfortable with it they had had it I'm
very interested in the voters that voted
for Obama and then Trump I don't feel
like the Democrats have done anything to
win back those votes I haven't I feel
like their economic arguments are pretty
poor and I remember Mitch McConnell
saying on-air at the state of the first
day of the Union after Trump wins after
that first year of his presidency
it's like Dana look at this list look at
all these things and in any Republican
administration if you didn't know who
would the president was but what would
Republicans be pleased and the answer is
arguably yes from judges and policy
deregulation all of these things have
made sense I also think that Republicans
are quite lucky that President Trump
decided to go with them
right because had he thought that there
was an opportunity and the timing was
right
he could have steamrolled over the
Democratic Party as well and well now
he's doing that he did never throw
publicans and now he's doing it with
them I I did recognize about two years
ago I said they're gonna come after the
electoral college
this is gonna be the new thing even
though Obama won the electoral college
they never talked about it again but now
they try to say that it's racist that
it's unfair and I said on top of Carl
shouldn't show and like watch they're
gonna come for the electoral college
it won't happen in our lifetime but it
is under threat so in a second I want to
ask you about sort of my theory that
that Trump is reaction to not only the
Obama years but in part to the Bush
years in an interesting way
but first big tech a lot of big tech it
ain't friendly to conservatives there
are a bunch of companies out there who
just don't like conservatives very much
I mean take a look at Twitter and what
they choose to trend and how they choose
to describe it it's just terrible well
if you can't trust certain elements in
Silicon Valley to treat conservatives
fairly how can you trust them to handle
your privacy and personal online data
that's why I recommend using expressvpn
every single time you go online big tech
companies can use your IP address to
match your internet activity to your
identity or a location when I use
expressvpn search engines and media
sites can't see my IP address at all my
identity is masked and anonymous
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting 100 percent of your data to
keep you safe from people who you don't
want to have your data expressvpn
software takes just a minute to set up
on your computer or phone you have one
button and you are now protected so if
you're like me and you believe that your
internet data belongs to you not to
giant tech companies who may not be
friendly to your values expressvpn is
the answer
protect your online activity today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe
visit expressvpn comm slash Ben to claim
an exclusive offer for my fans that's
expr ESS VPNs Aipom slash ban for three
months free with one year package again
that's visit expressive VPN comm slash
benda get started visit expressvpn comm
slash Ben right now get that three
months free with one year package and
protect all of your information no
reason for everybody else to monetize
your data when you should be in control
of that data expressvpn comm slash Ben I
want to throw out a theory about what
drove from directly over everybody in
the Republican Party including President
Bush's brother and and just steamrolled
everybody and that is there was this
roiling anger inside the Republican
Party dating all the way back to the
Bush administration in which Republicans
I think to a certain extent rightly felt
that Republicans had not defended
themselves against the predations of
perhaps President Trump has spent an
enormous amount of time bashing the
press it's one of the things that for
all of my quibbles with the way that he
acts with for all of my serious
criticisms of his character and even
from my criticisms of his overuse of the
term fake news when he's a hammer in
search of a nail and there are a lot of
nails for him to hit and for Republicans
it felt a lot during the Bush
administration like why won't President
Bush I come out and defend himself we're
out here fighting for him while and he
defend himself he was really frustrating
and then in 2008 John McCain had
somewhat of the same thing going on
where it was he was being savaged in the
press as a racist and as a bigot and as
and then he was suggest that he was Bush
term 3 even though he had significant
differences with President Bush and then
he was in the background saying well I'm
never ever going to mention Jeremiah
Wright and Republicans were what the
watch and then in 2012 it was Mitt
Romney the most genteel milquetoast
human being ever to walk the planet
running and his entire campaign was
basically Barack Obama's a really good
dude but marginal tax rates are out of
control and so along comes from pin 2016
and he's a giant pulsating middle finger
and a lot of Republicans just say okay
that guy because we're sick of this what
what do you make of that theory I think
that's right I also feel like but also
back in time if you go like after 9/11
and the country's at war one of the
worst things is enough inauthentic
behavior it wasn't imprisoned Bush's
nature although when Kanye West
suggested that he was a racist after
Hurricane Katrina he says that was the
thing that hurt him the most when he was
president as a leader you know he was a
turn the other cheek kind of guy focus
on the goal and I'm like that too and
and I think I just have to be Who I am
but sometimes that doesn't work so well
on cable news not a fighter really I
will argue my point but I also have a
longer-term view of life and a legacy
and I think that he probably did too I
imagine when I say that I thought about
what he would be thinking of me I
imagine he thought what would my parents
be thinking of me right and that he and
he has a deep faith and a relationship
with God and and he was going to live
that
so fast-forward when people are thinking
that their culture their very way of
life their very being is under assault
and then here comes somebody who was
willing to stick up for you there's
power in that and I it was very good
friends I am very good friends with
Brett Kavanaugh I've worked with him in
the White House I remember when I was a
spokesperson for Justice Roberts then
Judge Roberts that confirmation wasn't
easy people think that it was easy it
was easy after a chief Rehnquist passed
away because then there was another
opening and it was fine then Alito
became the target but at the time I
remember I didn't understand I'm not a
lawyer so I didn't understand why I was
getting all these questions about the
right to privacy I was like I thought
this was supposed to be about roe v wade
what are we do and I went to Brett
Kavanaugh on a Friday night 7:00 p.m. he
of course still there knock on the door
Lee could you help me and and he does he
helps walk me through it
watching what Brett Kavanaugh went
through when he was confirmed now when I
was his spokes a spokesperson no.5 the
big controversy about Brett kam and I
going to Circuit Court was that he had
written a torture memo or something or
he had said it tortured so that but
arguably all of these accusations about
his character and high school and
college would have been brought up you
know for oh no five never never heard a
whisper of it nothing and I was with my
husband in Spain on our 20th anniversary
on when cabin I did the second hearing
the second testimony and I've never seen
my husband outraged and I cried the
entire time and I really thought nothing
will unite conservatives like this and
when it's a choice between two people
whoever the Democrats come up with and
President Trump I think that the
Democrats are gonna have a really hard
time I mean so what what the hell
happened to the Democratic Party because
because something has gone deeply awry
here well maybe it's that they're having
their own moment right there having the
it's fast forward eight years from now
if we do this interview again we'll look
back and go oh
the Democrats were really mad because
whatever it might be I understand why
they're angry I think there was I do
think that there was the sense inside
the Democratic Party that they were
never going to lose another election and
the Barack Obama had forged a coalition
that was unbreakable because it did not
rely on traditional white voters and
that this was the growing demographics
as long as I have growing who's never
gonna lose yet they had kind of a
parallel situation they didn't deal with
Bernie Sanders early they changed the
rules to accommodate him he has a
following and movie he was even a
Democrat and it's just happened Trump
ran the tables
Bernie ran into the Hillary Clinton
bulwark basically and now they're all
still paying for it and they're going
through transition it's quite common for
a party to if they get to terms at a
White House which is almost always the
case but that next eight years is pretty
turbulent for whatever price I don't
know how the Democrats will end up
there's a lot of realignment going on
it's kind of fun too it's kind of fun to
live through it now I would say you know
2015 and 2016 I don't know if I loved
watching Republicans fight amongst
themselves but now I feel much more like
an observer and it's pretty fun to watch
and I hope there's a contested
convention at that for the Democrats
that'd be fun it hasn't had it I asked
Brady what's it like to cover a
contested convention he said I don't
know I've never done it so it could be
really a great history-making
so who do you think emerges and we're
gonna get in the political
prognostication game here and I've lost
too much money betting on politics to
actually do this much anymore but I'm
asking you to make money it costs money
but let's talk about the Democratic
primary process so right now you've got
Joe Biden who is well liked by a lot of
Republicans like I know a lot of senator
and senator Cruz who haven't really
opposed to him talks badly very friendly
a lot of Republicans are very friendly
with Joe Biden you know obviously I've
spent my entire career commenting from
the outside so I know very few
Democratic senators and a lot of
Republicans and very few Democrats and
so from the outside it has always
appeared to me that Joe Biden is a
political manipulator that he is fairly
good at that
but that he is actually sort of just a
genial kind of
bumbly guy does he look hungry for it no
um it's sort of like remember when you
read in the New York Times at Barack
Obama tells Joe you know have to do this
and it seems like that is kind of the
slogan for the campaign there's no real
verb because where's the energy and even
in his crowds it's like mmm like he's
he's then he's the next thing I do think
there's a lot of similarities to the
Romney candidacy thing is that the
Democrats keep hoping that his opponents
that he's going to crater he's not he
stays atop the polls so he won't crater
until one of them decides to go after
him right Castro tried failed think
about Marco Rubio Marco Rubio tries to
go after Trump fails and I think Bernie
is a kind of a nonentity he has a core
base of support they'll always be with
him but it's not growing not shrinking
he's not growing Camilla Harris you know
when you're pulling fifth in your home
state in Andrew yang who is authentic
and likable it does crowd surfing and I
get you it's just in fact if you're
fifth behind him in your home state
you've got you've got you've got
problems now you know changing
strategies I think about Elizabeth
Warren it's getting a lot of positive
press right now she has a lot of energy
when I talk about that you saw the media
talking about her for four hours of
taking selfies it's called a photo line
but I think selfies whatever you want to
call it there's energy in her speech and
now at her speeches people are finishing
her lines like they've gone back
multiple times they like her so there is
something there was it Elizabeth Warren
but I would say this she missed her
moment she should have ran in 2016 she
should not have endorsed Hillary should
have should have taken on Bernie and she
would have been the candidate against
Trump I don't know how that would have
turned out yeah I mean I think that
that's I feel the same way because I
feel like as you say her press has been
in airing Lee glowing I mean since the
Pocahontas stuff she it's been just
endless great press for her and I think
that now that Bernie is starting to drop
in the polls he's going to have to come
out
with a hot poker I mean there's just
really has no choice right and when that
happens he's gonna hit her her
inauthenticity and he's going to be
right because she is inauthentic I mean
she's been playing it I'm the authentic
progressive voice in the room she is
certainly not I mean if you go back and
you read what she was writing in 2003
2004 she was actually kind of
interesting in heterodox and now she's
cribbing off a Bernie sheet and then
pretending that she came up with all
these ideas herself I mean even Stephen
Colbert exposed her on the middle-class
tax stuff so I think that that Biden is
default candidate and I do think that
Biden's candidacy has a serious shot
against Trump just because default
Democrat could do fairly well against
Trump because of his personal foible
meaning that running a dead person
against against Trump might not actually
be the worst strategy yeah you don't
necessarily need somebody who is
transformational and in future it's
gonna be close no matter what although I
also think about this with the Democrats
and maybe this is true for Republicans
as well probably is the governor's that
used to be seen as great presidential
candidates because they've been
executives of a state they they're not
from Washington but here's the thing
they're not on TV all the time nobody
knows them so you hear you have governor
hook Hickenlooper and governor Bullock
two very accomplished people can't get a
foothold and I think part of that is
that there's just so much national
attention now rather than state based
let's talk for a second about the
transformation in the Republican Party
so you mentioned all the chaos inside
their party in 2015 2016 so how do you
think that the new Republican Party
stacks up to sort of the Bushehr
Republican Party what what's changed and
what's the same well I think that um I
think that a lot of the people who were
Reaganites this come through even - even
to today but one thing also you I
thought you were you would mention that
Republicans were very frustrated with
the Bush administration for spending I
think those the tea party bid didn't
seem to matter with Trump
it doesn't now right so that is that's a
quick change in eight years but Chris
and Soltis Anderson as well she's not
the only one but she told me about this
chart where the majority of people are
not fiscally conservative and socially
liberal no one else basically yeah
they're socially conservative and
fiscally liberal and that's where you
have somebody like Elizabeth Warren
saying
I will increase the average social
security check by $200 a month doesn't
nobody cares how she's gonna pay for it
I am some things like on that what would
president Trump say right as all of a
sudden it's like well we can't do that
because no I think they up the ante so I
just keep going and the consequences of
this kind of spending and debt deficit
it seems to me that we took a lot of
grief for that and the Bush
administration that you don't hear so
much now maybe that's okay maybe it
doesn't matter maybe you could get to
higher growth maybe you know deficit so
III don't know it it is kind of a
partisan thing thing spending
Republicans care about it during the
Obama years maybe not so much during the
Trump years Democrats railed about it in
the bush years or not it's I think the
spending issue is is super important I
also think that there's some innovation
that needs to be done and I like states
doing the experiments especially when it
comes to health care if we could figure
out a way to unleash the free market to
be able to allow competition in some way
to help with health care I do think that
Americans would realize we don't have to
go to a medicare-for-all model that will
break the country there's some rallying
to be done but the Republicans right now
you you have to ask you're um campaigns
like what do you want to do in a second
term can we answer that like what do you
want to do now most people would say
stave off the crazy and that might be
enough it really might be it might be
enough but I also wonder like what kind
of the other thing is and I always keep
this in mind remember I said the
President Bush ran to do these things
911 happened changes everything I've
always were like something could happen
I think for President Obama it was when
Ed Snowden released all of those
documents changes everything
reveals all the nation's secrets causing
huge problems all around the world
nothing has ever really been the same
for president Trump and it happened yet
but the Iranians hitting a Saudi oil
facility it's pretty big deal so let's
talk about how you maintain being a
happy well-adjusted and I
person in this space because that is
indeed a rarity and that there are nice
people but you are I have yet to hear
anyone say a bad word about you which is
an amazing thing dr. Greg Gutfeld you
might give you a few you know everybody
has bad things to say about Greg yeah
he's I really don't think that I would
actually have the career I have now
without Greg because he really gave me
the confidence to come out of my shell I
remember Brian Kilmeade one time filled
in for Greg and he said I had no idea
you are funny it's like well we were at
war I was raised Lutheran my of course I
like the gold star on the chart extended
to Sunday school I ever lied on my faith
many times and I'm grateful to have it
it's so funny like sometimes you forget
that you need you can be a little bit
lacks in your relationship with God and
then something will yank you back to
reality you think you think you can try
to fix it and you realize oh no actually
you need to turn it over and the
Serenity Prayer is really important to
me so knowing what I can do what I can't
do in the wisdom to know the difference
as something that I think is important I
also think there's just maybe it's not a
wyoming thing but I feel like this is
where I got it there's a dignity and in
self-control and I'm just saying calm
and for example at the podium I never
let anyone see me rattled and President
Bush used to say you might think she's
nice but she's tougher than you realize
and maybe a little bit that of that too
is that I hold a lot of it in but I
learned a lot from President Bush I
remember for the end there was a
interview with these two great guys
Terry hunt and Steve Holland AP and
Reuters they were like Frick and frack
they came everywhere with us and haha
Holland is still there at the White
House today Thank You Man interview the
president the last moment and they the
president said something about oh yeah
bail Clint was here yesterday for lunch
and they're like
really I think we didn't know and he
didn't put out a press release every
time and they asked are you friendly
yeah we are he said you know I call him
on the days when nobody else would
remember when the Obama team went after
him in South Carolina suggesting that he
was a racist he said I called him on
that day and I always remembered that
like oh call your friends on their
hardest day you called me once on a hard
day and I also remember this at the end
of the administration Peter and I were
headed to Africa a little vacation but
also volunteer at a PEPFAR site and I
leaned my head back against the chair
and I said nothing I do for the rest of
my life will ever be this difficult or
this important and it really hasn't and
I'm so grateful to be an American to
have the opportunities that I've been
given I haven't had a lot of hardship I
also can't stand disruption drama I hate
it when others are mean and maybe it has
to do also if I go back to being bused I
think that had a real impact on me like
the worry that somebody wasn't going to
like me or seeing somebody else be hurt
and my parents were very helpful to
refugees so on the weekends through
Lutheran Family Services and Lutheran
World Relief we would help resettle
refugees from the former Soviet Union
and I think that gave me a real
appreciation for being out of your
comfort zone also it's life's short want
to do want to live mean sometimes I
laugh in spite of myself about president
Trump's nicknames the only one I really
liked was little Rocket Man for personal
reasons I didn't personal bias reason
slightly Steve with my personal I
understand the power of it and the the
marketing and the skill and the
political acumen the president's super
smart about that right he has the
strategy
I just know like it would hurt me to see
somebody made fun of was probably I'll
never run for office
no probably I'm never running for office
ever nobody's
no ogle room there so no I'm not going
I'm not gonna do it so for folks who
don't know your husband Peter is just a
delight so how did you get how did you
guys meet like I only met him recently
I've known you for a while but I've only
met him I'm so glad you got to meet him
because such a kick also because he
listens to Ben Shapiro every day and he
does this long walk in the mornings with
Jasper at the park and and sometimes he
comes back sick did you hear what Ben of
course I heard what Ben said because I
always I listen to so I'm glad that
Peter and I have you to share as in our
fandom we have an 18 year age difference
I was 25 when I met him on an airplane
we were seated next to each other our
seat assignments he we were going from
Denver to Chicago and I was going on
from Chicago to DC and it was really
love at first sight and I moved to
England eight months later lived there
for a year with him and then we came
back to the States
in 1998-99 and then 9/11 happened and we
came back and he has one of the things
in my book and the good news is that I
talked about is my favorite piece of
advice is that choosing to be loved is
not a career limiting decision I think a
lot of people put off relationships or
marriage or family because they think
they want to achieve a certain level of
professional success and then they'll
find love and do all of those things and
I try to tell people it doesn't it
doesn't have to work that way I actually
feel like I couldn't have done any of
this without Peter and then of course
there's Jasper so you've written full
books about Jasper so what what guy my
wife is trying to get me into it right
now really trying totally gonna cave I
am for security reasons too because I
keep being told that if he if you that
if you really want to be secure in your
house then you need to have a dog
outside so this is I maintain I've
always maintained this when Elizabeth
Smart was kidnapped if they had had a
dog it never what happened yeah I get
this a lot so Mike my kids are into it
my wife is into it I have a feeling
within a few years I'll be yeah exactly
I will be a dog acolyte and all of my
prior anti dogs for the time that you
sent me you're gonna do an ad for some
sort of dog thing and you said to me
like no you should take this one this is
more for Dana yeah that was exactly
right it is it is one more awkward ad
reads and
and that's saying something
oh ya know there have been some real bad
ones and that one definitely is like
right up up with dogs and especially on
the ranch and the dog my grandfather was
such a good dog trainer my uncle's two
very very good drug trainers so I
learned that I had a dog with Peter we
got him in Scotland Hungarian Vizsla
breed Shorthair sleek they're sweet
smart
Henry was with me from when I was 26 to
when I was 40 one of the things I love
about dogs is that they don't care that
in that time I became the White House
press secretary and moved to New York
and was on the five they're just your
constant it really is you know man's
best friend the other thing is Greta Van
Susteren called me the night Henry died
about six months after we moved to New
York and she said doctor get another one
so how could I do that I live in New
York and there's no grass and well she
was right and so that's we got Jasper
Jasper has grown up with the five he is
seven and a half years old I believe
that dogs help bring a family closer
together
not that you need that I know I'm not
trying to oh no come on listen keep
making the case if you are arguing with
your spouse or you like having a tough
day but you go out for a walk with the
dog it really is a tension reliever
because you laugh at them a little funny
or they worry about them whatever it
might be also they're a great buffer for
politics like when I go to dog park
I know talk politics anybody like oh
sorry I meant dog park yeah and you have
to try to find commonalities with your
fellow humans and right now people feel
very polarized or they feel like that I
don't know if you get this I this lady
ran into me in the street the other day
Oh Dana I just wanna say hi I love your
show I'm a Democrat but I love your show
why do you have to say that right and
what I found is that if you have a dog
like oh your dogs so cute and then it
becomes like oh your dogs cute you know
and then you don't have to have the
thing I'm a Republican I'm a Democrat
I'm a libertarian I'm so conservative
look whatever it is there's no identity
politics at the dog park except if you
have a visa which is a superior breed so
in one second I want to ask you a final
question which is going to be whether
Dana Perino believes that there is hope
for a nicer America we'll get to that
question in just one segment if you want
to hear Dana's answer you have to be a
daily one
subscriber to subscribe head on over to
daily wire.com click subscribe watch the
rest of our conversation they're old and
I'm putting to thank you so much for
stopping by it's always great to see you
and look forward to having you on when
we start doing repeats oh great that'll
be great and I may not but in the
meantime we'll continue to allow the Ben
Shapiro sure to bring your marriage
closer together okay thank you that's
that's what we do here thank you so much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy borin associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Maynard post-production is supervised by
Alex Zangara editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Kamino
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
pedal graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20